in the 2030s thanks to the rapidly
increasing oil prices
qatar's economy was booming out of
control this led to the country heavily
investing and trying to combat nature's
plan
and turn the desert into fertile land
and for a while there
it was working but then the oil ran out
by the 2040s the sand was winning the
fight and slowly the city was being
taken back by the desert
it was only those who could afford to
leave that did while the rest remained
under the led skyline
that doha was once famous for then
following the overwhelming sandstorms
was famine and government protest and
within no time at all the military
police
were everywhere they were trying their
best to stop qatar
from being the next country to follow in
the non-patriotic trend that was
occurring across the planet
in the year 2040 a journalist called
kevin bitcher was surfing through the
dark net
in pursuit of information around the no
pets the soldiers who didn't have a
place they could call home
who also happened to be enemy number one
in the eyes of government officials
suddenly during the early hours of the
morning kavan was contacted by an
anonymous source
claiming to be the most wanted man alive
oz
oz was the commander of the largest
known group of nopat forces
however kavan had received messages like
this before and time and time again
it ended up being absolutely nothing or
in some situations it was government
agents
working on the anti-nopat campaigns he
even once had a guy accuse him
of being oz but what happened next
proved that there was something
different about this particular source
moments after the chat ended qatari
police broke down the door
accusing kavan of aiding a terrorist
fortunately for him an approaching
sandstorm provided a window of
opportunity for him to escape a rest
and whilst using the cover of the storm
to hide from the armored vehicles that
were looking for him
kavan began to notice some strange
messages coming through on the massive
overhead led signage
through these adverts he was able to see
the notepad emblem flashing through
along with a number of other mysterious
symbols and images
piecing these together kevin followed
what he thought could be a way to find
the no pets
and even if it wasn't he couldn't
exactly hang around where he was for
very long
half of the city was looking for him
following the clues he ended up at the
underground construction
far beneath the abandoned football
stadium
outside a man in his 50s dressed in
casual knee-length shorts
points his flashlight towards the tunnel
entrance his relaxed appearance and body
language confused kevin
what was going on the man then thrust
out his hand towards him
and said toyota guskovsky and then in
perfect arabic
said this was a one-time thing as kevin
makes his way down through the dark
tunnels
he wonders if he'll ever be able to call
doha home again
but as he found out a year later qatar
would become a failed state
and the city of doha lost to sand
[Music]
almost two months after leaving doha the
trail of clues kavan was following
led him to alain india there he found a
safe house
made up of shipping containers and
inside
were a number of heavily armed no pet
soldiers
after speaking with them kevin
discovered that this group included a
former intelligence officer doctor
nightclub bouncer and car mechanic
one of the men a man named nevin rau
seemed more approachable than the rest
he was a notorious indian hacker an
ex-special forces officer
of the indian navy rao explained that
during the 30s
armed task force units started to pop up
around the globe
to help assist in moving cargo around
the world and between the non-patrioted
all because countries were unwilling to
help feed the stranded families
so the no pets took it upon themselves
unfortunately these operations were
about to become even more dangerous
and when the world's governments started
to crack down on the no pets
they began treating these units like
smugglers and pirates
this particular task force that kevin
had stumbled across was missing
something that was reasonably integral
to the operation
a boat it was all starting to make sense
to him now
this is why this group of individuals
are in a lang one of the largest ship
breaking yards in the world
they were going to commandeer one
unsurprisingly after the second great
depression in the late 30s
there was very little to be shipped
around the world
so the shipping transportation industry
decided to recoup some of its costs
by turning to ship braking facilities
and convert their unused fleets
back into high tensile steel
however elaine soon became famous for
something else
as the ships destined for scrap metal
started magically disappearing
and then only to be discovered months
later amongst the ever-growing no-pap
fleet
and it was soon discovered that corrupt
businessmen were using the black market
to sell these ships to the no pets
once the indian military found out about
this they immediately began setting up
patrols and guards
in every attempt to shut it down
intrigued cavend decides to join the
nopats on their mission
navigating the alien coast is an
incredibly treacherous business at the
best of times
and in the gale force winds that night
and whilst pursued by the indian army
the gunfire sounded like it was coming
from every direction
during their mission at one point rao
was struck by a bullet
yet occasionally brushed it off and took
the helm piloting them around the black
iron corpses of ships
that blocked their escape route with
25-foot swells
he navigated the ship with ease leaving
their pursuers far behind their wake
and stuck surrounded by the graveyard of
tankers
by 1 32 am the magic act was complete
and they had vanished far across the
21st parallel
and the beat up old container ship now
unofficially named
the copperfield began her journey as a
no pet
incoming five
attention all squads the russian troops
are falling back
do whatever you can to secure the sector
[Applause]
we push them back but not far enough do
not let them regroup